en este vídeo voy a hablar acerca de
algunas de las funciones del sistema
nervioso y de cómo las clasificó y
organizó en mi mente el sistema nervioso
realiza funciones muy diversas que les
permiten a las personas experimentar su
vida y que crean su comportamiento así
como muchas funciones necesarias para el
cuerpo las cuales normalmente las
personas no se dan cuenta estas
funciones pueden categorizar se en
diferentes maneras a mí me gusta
clasificar las funciones del sistema
nervioso en dos grandes categorías las
funciones básicas del sistema nervioso y
las funciones superiores del sistema
nervioso aquí pueden usar otras palabras
para describir las por ejemplo las
funciones bajas y las funciones altas o
las funciones básicas y las funciones
complejas pero la razón por la que yo
prefiero usar estos términos es porque
las funciones básicas no son para nada
sencillas y tampoco son bajas desde
ningún punto de vista ambas son
necesarias por eso yo me refiero a ellas
como las funciones básicas y las
funciones superiores
al funcionamiento de diversas partes del
sistema nervioso puede ocasionar
diferentes patrones anormales de sus
funciones ya sean de las básicas de las
superiores o de ambas a los patrones de
anormalidades de las funciones les
llamamos síndromes que son patrones
anormales a ciertos síndromes que
involucran funciones anormales del
sistema nervioso son más comunes que
otros debido a que son ocasionados por
desórdenes neurológicos o psiquiátricos
que ocurren con mayor frecuencia las
funciones básicas del sistema nervioso
son realizadas por diversas partes tanto
del sistema nervioso central que son el
encéfalo y la médula espinal y del
sistema nervioso periférico que son los
nervios y hablando de nervios
los nervios craneales realizan
principalmente las funciones básicas de
la cabeza y el cuello mientras que los
nervios espinales realizan
principalmente las funciones básicas del
tronco y de las extremidades ya que es a
dónde llegan estos nervios yo divido las
funciones básicas del sistema nervioso
en tres categorías la primera categoría
es
y en este contexto motora se refiere al
control de los músculos esqueléticos los
músculos principales que tenemos por
todo el cuerpo pegados al esqueleto y al
controlar los músculos esqueléticos la
función motora del sistema nervioso
ocasiona movimiento tono y postura que
son los resultados finales de la
contracción de los músculos esqueléticos
la siguiente categoría de las funciones
básicas del sistema nervioso son las
funciones sensoriales y esto involucra a
todos los sentidos básicamente cualquier
cosa que pueda detectar el sistema
nervioso es común escuchar acerca de los
cinco sentidos pero resulta que si los
dividimos en categorías más finas hay
mucho más que cinco sentidos la vista el
oído el olfato el gusto está el sentido
del oído interno llamado sentido
vestibular y hay varias sensaciones
corporales llamadas somato sensación y
ésta incluye el sentido del tacto de la
posición de las partes del cuerpo
vibración dolor temperatura y otros más
en futuros vídeos veremos con mayor
detalle
las categorías ya que hay muchas cosas
que ocurren en cada una de ellas y la
tercera categoría es de las funciones
automáticas estas funciones no se
realizan de forma consciente e incluyen
muchas cosas como los reflejos por
ejemplo cuando el doctor golpea
levemente la rodilla y uno mueve la
pierna sin ordenarle que lo haga hay
varios reflejos en el sistema nervioso
veremos algunos de ellos con mayor
detalle en futuros vídeos además hay
muchas otras funciones automáticas que
no requieren de la conciencia para
realizarlas esto incluye el control de
muchos sistemas importantes en el cuerpo
como la circulación la respiración y la
digestión más adelante veremos esto con
mayor detalle con respecto a las
funciones superiores del sistema
nervioso no son realizadas por grandes
porciones del sistema nervioso central o
del periférico las funciones superiores
son realizadas por partes del encéfalo y
como las funciones básicas del sistema
nervioso podemos clasificar las
funciones superiores en tres categorías
la primera categoría de las funciones
superiores del sistema nervioso es la
cognitiva y las personas usan este
término de diversas formas por lo que
puede ser confuso leer acerca de esto
pero podemos pensar en esto como la
parte pensante del cerebro además de
pensar hay muchas otras cosas que
podemos incluir en esta parte cognitiva
como el aprendizaje la memoria el
lenguaje y otro grupo de funciones que
llamamos funciones ejecutivas que
involucran cosas como establecer metas y
organizar el comportamiento para
alcanzar esas metas más adelante veremos
esto con más detalle porque hay mucho
que aprenderá al respecto la siguiente
categoría de las funciones superiores
son las emociones y las emociones se
refieren a los sentimientos pero también
hay cosas que están relacionadas con las
emociones además de los sentimientos ya
que las emociones tienen un papel
importante en nuestra experiencia de la
vida así como en otras funciones del
sistema nervioso y del resto del cuerpo
y la última categoría de las funciones
superiores del sistema nervioso es la
conciencia
conciencia es una palabra muy difícil de
definir yo no creo tener una gran
definición de conciencia porque desde
hace mucho tiempo se ha tratado de
determinar una definición con la que
todos estén de acuerdo aunque tenemos
una idea de lo que es la conciencia pero
puedo decir que está relacionada con la
percepción de ser una persona de la
experiencia de la propia vida y del
control de las acciones propias y aunque
aún hay muchas cosas que aún no
comprendemos acerca de prácticamente
todas las categorías de funciones que
escribía aquí la consciencia es de la
que menos sabemos hay muchas personas
haciendo mucha investigación para tratar
de comprender cómo el sistema nervioso
crea este fenómeno de la conciencia así
es como yo clasificó las funciones del
sistema nervioso y como me gusta
separarlas en estas categorías las
cuales veremos con mayor detalle en
futuros vídeos si buscan esto en los
libros de texto verán que las personas
han organizado estas funciones de muchas
formas diferentes aunque realmente no
importa como organizamos las funciones
del sistema nervioso lo importante es
encontrar una
de que esto tenga sentido para nosotros
y podamos comprenderlo